the king of Wango Tango yes for the last
22 years the biggest names in music have
been here on this stage and tonight is
no different such an epic lineup you
have Taylor you have the Jonas Brothers
do you make the calls at this point to
get people like no I do not I I wish I
could tell you that I had the power to
do that this shows been what 22 years
old I've done it 16 times it is it is
like kicking off summer in the best way
outside in Southern California with all
these great songs that will be on
everybody summer playlist I feel like
one of the best perks of your job is
that you get to listen to songs in
advance like I know you heard me yeah
have you heard any of the unreleased
Jonas Brothers or Taylor stuff um no but
is the documentary the Jennifers out I
saw it I've ever seen I saw that and I
sent Nick a text saying I cried twice in
it
emotional was it about that I'm pretty
easily emotional but no it's just just
to see what they overcame they really
had to overcome some difficult things as
brothers and to see them doing it back
together
I'll it was on an airplane going oh my
god question Kourtney Kardashian said
she would be happy if the cameras went
away why are you so [ __ ] these days
how do you feel about that and how many
more seasons of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians first you go if the cameras
go away as long as they can come back
Courtney you know they can go away for a
little bit but bring them back so we can
do another season or two and listen I
don't know how honestly I don't know how
they do it they've lived for over a
decade with cameras following I could
not do it and no matter what they were
paying them I couldn't do it so I give
them a lot of credit from those cameras
in their lives all the time and I love
you coordinator I love Courtney - do you
ever be The Bachelor I don't think I'd
be good at it no I don't think so I
don't think I'd be good at remembering
all of the different things I have -
romantic I'd be great at it but I'm
gonna be the best I like watching it I
like watching it but yeah I think I'm
better the spectator maybe being the
bachelor but who knows
[Music]